this project is a bit bra broad so it
touches a lot of different things
first of all ie assume that you guys
know what malaria is right yeah okay I
want you to have two things in mind
about malaria okay the first of all
you'll know and is that malaria kills
okay malaria
actually it's not just that it kills it
devastates it's something that goes
super quick between the people and you
die super quick it destroys families the
destroys villages and even I've heard
this horrible thing that people in
Africa used to tell themselves that kids
doesn't get a soul until until the age
of five and they say that so they don't
feel bad if a kid dies so that's that's
actually horrible yeah every 59 seconds
a kid died of malaria so it's a big
problem
as you can see malaria to spread
worldwide okay most in the tropical
countries but nowaday with a global
warming half of the population of the
world is in areas where malaria is
suitable to be so the other big problem
actually now south of Italy is out of
Spain would be would have the declared
climate conditions to have malaria so
it's a problem still neither luckily but
yeah we have to be careful as you know
it's transmitted by mosquito and there's
five kinds of malaria the good thing is
that only one of the kinds is the one
that kills people the bad things that
this kind is the one that is present in
75% of the cases so that's a lot a lot
of problem so then the symptoms are
let's also another problem in terms of
malaria are really standards in terms
you have fever you have headache
you have articulation pain so that's
something that if you go to a doctor
they will have no clue what you have
that's why you need to be diagnosis
diagnosis the diagnosis the diagnosis is
a bit tricky so first of all there's
like this diagnosis with
trips this super cheap super easy just
need a blood sample of blood like this
and you put the paper and depending on
the color you you know if you have
malaria or not the problem is the
specificity specificity of this is
horrible it goes as low as 50% so that's
it that's literally [ __ ] the good way to
test malaria is with a microscope so you
need a microscope and a person to look
through the microscope the thing it's
super great you just need a sample of
blood you put some substance to remove
the hemoglobin so then you can see
different lighter so you can see through
the different layers of blood to check
their process and the problem it's
obvious you need someone to check the
microscope all the time
and if you have a village that has 2,000
people and they start having malaria you
have to check them all every day so you
cannot do that the big problem with
malaria is that people are not dying
because malaria is difficult illness
they're dying because they are not
getting properly diagnose it so that's
the biggest problem if you can malaria
and data tag you in the next three days
it's super easy to cure it it's super
super easy actually had a friend who had
malaria a couple of weeks ago and she
got antibiotics for two or three days
and she was perfectly fine afterwards
and yet the second thing that I want you
to have in mind is malaria screwball you
just need quickly notice that's the key
thing so people are dying because they
don't get quick diagnosis so yeah I'm at
one I'm from Barcelona and I'm not a
developer I'm not a developer at all I'm
an engineer I'm a mechanical engineer
and I kind of work in different projects
all the time really super different
projects one day I went to the fall I
found a fall scope the fall scope is a
microscope that you may have seen that
in a TED talk
it's from the Stanford University and
there was this guy who had this amazing
idea to make a foldable microscope that
cost something around 50 cents and then
you can send it worldwide and everybody
would have a microscope and check
if they have several things as you can
say malaria tuberculosis a lot of things
but then I thought to myself yeah that's
amazing but you still need a doctor and
actually the doctor is the expensive
part the microscope you can buy them on
Amazon
dr. is certainly that needs way more
work so then I thought ok let's put some
machine learning and solve the part of
the doctor put some computer vision and
solve the part of the doctor so I
decided to build this whole thing tiny
device which you will blow a drop of
blood and it will tell you if you have
malaria or not so first I started
designing the microscope and I started
with the idea the fall scope and then I
check it I I started and I got to this
so that's in the right height that's my
screen of my cell phone and in the left
that supported me to be blood so
obviously I failed
III did fail that's horrible
that shouldn't be like this so the
iPhone scope works like [ __ ]
full-coverage horrible yeah yeah or
maybe I don't know how to use it but I
really really check it and I was reading
the papers and everything so I keep
developing different prototypes I was
checking the internet lenses with lenses
of laser pointers a bit better than this
but nothing that I could work with and
after I think I had like really like
literally like 17 process dives and a
friend of mine told me like hey don't be
stupid you have like a big project to do
don't focus on the microscope so buy a
microscope so I bought this Chinese
microscopy in Amazon that cost me 15
euros that was supposed to be thousand x
magnification that was exactly what I
needed so that was amazing so I still
super cheered so yeah for example that's
a sample of blood through this
microscope and yeah it was amazing as
you can compare with the previous
it's a bit better right actually it's
the same sample so yeah
the problem that I checked and it's only
200 X so I can work with that I cannot
work with this microscope it has a
sensor of 0.3 megapixels and only 200 X
so I cannot even do a digital
magnification there was a problem with
UCF we are a bunch of nerds here
I also did a picture of my screen that's
super nice you can compare way better so
then I was actually the desperated
like [ __ ] this thing is never going to
work this the part of the microscope I
can't forget and one day I was a knight
and I thought I talked I taught myself
oh ok let's solve it let's open this
microscope and make it work you can make
it work you're an engineer you have been
making work a lot of stuff so then I
start thinking of the physical
connotations of this project and a bit
of the idea was I that I God that was
the father you put your sensor the
bigger the image is so then I thought oh
can it change the geometry of the sensor
and I put it a big trial remove there
all central was 0.3 megapixel and I
added one of 8 megapixels 3 million 3
centimeters further so and with these 3
centimeters you can see here you can see
like purple blood
yeah that's except when are you having a
whole month working on that that success
that yeah you can see the same the same
pixels and the previous ones th huge is
huge so 10 times the group of three is a
millimeter so yeah it's actually pretty
cheap I pretty pretty pretty nice and
yeah I hope a banana for the scale here
so the second part how to calculate
everything so I wanted to do it super
cheap and super standard so I decided
myself to use the Raspberry Pi the model
3 the the last one it's portable cheap
and standard it runs tensorflow
but it's amazing it's a nightmare to
insulting a floater but like literally a
9
it took me three days it just keep
crashing all the time all the time you
keep like bad whatever but it works it
works nice I also I thought we were
gonna go to the system but I could run
here perfectly the neural networks and
also run forests SVM's and it worked
really really nice and I was surprised
of the velocity of the of the Raspberry
Pi it's way way way quicker than I was
expecting so finally here that's malaria
okay that's a sample of malaria and as
you can see mark those dots here in in
the middle those are the parasites you
can see that there's like a dot and
sometimes that surrounds it a bit okay
that's like the ring of the parasite
that's the reproduction form of the
parasite that's the one that you can
find in the blood so first of all as I
said you need to put this a typical
product to remove the hemoglobin and you
get this then I focused on the to check
the dark areas for the reason that I
wanted it to be computationally less
expensive as possible I could have lunch
agreed everywhere use a convolutional
neural network to find the important
places but I thought that the best thing
was to do this kind of grid here and run
it all over the grid it still needs to
improve okay that's a project I've been
working on that for like two months
Phil needs to go brother but yeah
basically I focus on the dark areas to
check with a neural network with the
convolutional neural network all the if
I find malaria or not so actually the
the process super simple its input we
have the picture we run the CNN the
convolutional neural network and then
try to locate the precedes whenever you
are running the neural network you get
the sample here you don't see that what
is super here they look like nipples
but you can see like the like the main
area here and there's this tiny thing
that's malaria okay actually all of the
four of them it's malaria in different
parts of the grid I want to locate them
all and then decide which one I like the
best
okay I know I could do other strategies
but this one was the one that for me was
less computationally expensive and the
one that worked the best for all the
tests that I did so after this you get
something like this with all the
possible malaria dollars so you have
more than one for each dot so then I use
just clustering is it clustering I think
there's no secret in that and flop and I
get just one for each one this one has
two but yeah mostly that's the idea then
the problem here is not to locate so if
I fell of one it's not a problem because
if you only have one person you have
malaria so the thing that here you have
to or whatever it's not a big big deal
as you can see the metrics the ROC curve
looks like if I took it from a book and
the reason for that is that the parasite
have a really standard form they are
actually really easy to locate something
that if you trained yourself for two
hours you can locate them by yourself
this is easy there's the thing with the
position under recall I believe that
here everybody would think that recall
is the most important parameter here you
don't want false negatives you don't
want to tell someone that doesn't has
malaria and they have malaria but here
the detail opposite when you oh one is
position these matters here at for its
dot okay they are not for the whole
picture is for each dot so I don't care
missing two points three points it's
okay because I wanna I'm gonna have 15
points in each picture but I don't want
to tell someone that doesn't have
malaria that has malaria because if I
have a recall of 0.9 almost that means
that if I have a dot I might say it's
malaria I may say it's not malaria but
if I have to I will definitely say you
have malaria and you have I only have on
if I have more
sure I would tell you you have malaria
so that's not the problem the problem is
the procedure here so that's and that
this yes ninety nine point three to
still low so now I'm already working
with more data I'm working with a image
pre-processing to try to make the
malaria look more malaria yeah yes
Antonia doesn't look that malaria
the problem with malaria with this
method that that I'm using this thick
blood method that it is a standalone did
you were checking different layers and
but you can only focus with the
microscope one of the liars so the other
layers you cannot see them okay but not
that well so that's a problem that why
precision is super important because it
can confuse other dot the turn on
malaria with malaria
let the biggest the the biggest problem
and at the end I want the whole thing to
work like a thermometer i I would like
people to use it as a key had to say
like if you check it yourself there in
your billet and if you have malaria you
go to a doctor to get proper treatment
so this machine will never tell you what
to take which kind of pills you need but
it will tell it tell you hey you need to
run because yeah because malaria can
tells you in actually within hours but
the most normal its within days and
weeks so you do wanna run yeah as a the
amazing thing computer vision can
diagnose malaria that actually something
I'm super happy to be able to say that
something so the unless malaria can be
solved with computer vision and also the
thing that that should improve doctors
life because that should be expanded
spending their time doing things that
brings more value they cannot spend ten
hours a day checking a microscope that
can be done by a machine so that makes
no sense now in the moment that we are
living now we're living in the moment
that we have more the biggest
intelligence ever and it's our
responsibility to use it for good things
and the amazing thing the whole thing
it cost under 50 years that not a crazy
thing and I believe that whenever I can
3d print the microscope it's gonna be
even lower it's gonna be like 40 euros
so that's for me from my point of view
it's kind of a revolution that this kind
of easy task can be done by a doctor i
buy a machine not a doctor I think
that's a game-changer yeah it's it's
time to fight malaria malaria and other
illnesses so thank you very much you can
check the website of the project okay
you can add me on LinkedIn you can
whatever you can see me hi and yeah
thank you thank you very much
[Applause]
[Applause]